hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
checking up a trailer today for a horror
movie that was sent to me I was watching
VHS last night with Sally and Veronica
now I'm gonna check out the trailer for
bite and I want to give a heads up I'm
gonna be out of town for the next three
days gonna have no service going on a
camping trip slash music festival equals
rave meaning [ __ ] and bikinis dancing
but I can't look at them cuz I got a
girlfriend that is really [ __ ] hot so
it's okay to not look at other [ __ ]
my girlfriend's out a [ __ ] she's a
woman an angel I'm sorry baby I'm just
digging myself a deeper hole here I
think this is an indie horror flick
let's see what's going on
whoa it looks infected
I need to speak to a doctor [ __ ] go to
the ER yesterday I felt something coming
from inside cuz you're scaring me look
what happened monster
what the [ __ ] is going on
hi I'm Valerie Valerie that's really
upbeat news Wow huh
interesting concept you go into the
water you get bit by something and then
you come back and eternally it kind of
reminds me of films like the fly an
infection movie that slowly takes over
your body but this trailer kind of
showed uh a hell of a lot it sort of
just went to here's what she turns into
even though it's not that clear you're
still like well I would like to have
seen a little bit of a slower more
moving evolution of this creature she's
becoming I don't know if this is like I
almost a home invasion but you know a
movie that mainly takes place in this
home it kind of looks like that as far
as the execution of it it looks pretty
cool you know I read somewhere that the
first screening of this movie was so
scary I don't know if this is true or
not but I heard that first screening of
this movie was so [ __ ] scary that
people had to be taken away in the
ambulance hey buddy no yeah you can just
chill there if you want but that fact
alone is what scares me if people
actually fainted either they're like
incredible [ __ ] like that one time I
watch that Mortal Kombat X video because
I heard these guys fainted or really is
a terrifying film I it's gotta be scary
in some way it looks a little freaky and
plus you know the girls still kind of
hot for someone who turns into a freaky
looking thing anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope
Marc Anthony Castillo yo give me a shout
out in the next vid please Wow
wow you really follow the rules of a
shout out request you're supposed to say
something interesting what the [ __ ] am I
gonna go off here Marc Anthony Castillo
how can I give you a unique shout-out
look Marc Anthony your name's Marc
Anthony how unfortunate that guy was
hands down
JLo's least attractive ex-husband and
you got the same [ __ ] name as him ah
you've earned this show